and you want to know me for why do I  want to know you because you're gonna be  in Bryson's life every single day no  one's really protective over Bryson I  feel like I have a right to know who's  gonna be around my grandson what are  your intentions here in the u.s. what I  have to tell you that I don't feel cold  I don't understand why you found Robert  on the internet and you talk to him for  two years supposedly and then all of a  sudden you're here in America full force  in his life and what you have to know  that for because it's going to affect my  grandsons I want a fig note absolutely  it will because I'm gonna be with Bryson  for forever I'll be at his graduations I  love those events I was trying to be  nice and friendly in court so it was me  way personal question there's no be nice  she come to me like all those questions  please crazy she's rude she's bad I  don't like her  [Music]